elon musk has recently been tweeting all
kinds of crazy stuff about free speech
in the platform of twitter he even ran a
poll where he stated free speech is
essential to a functioning democracy do
you believe twitter rigorously adheres
to this principle and he allowed for
voting and two million people voted no
over 70 percent of people said
absolutely not twitter does not
rigorously adhere to this principle elon
then followed it up with another tweet
where he said the consequences of this
poll will be important please vote
carefully now while all this has been
going on you have to remember that
twitter's been experiencing a number of
changes as well jack dorsey stepped down
in november it replaced him with a brand
new ceo that already worked at the
business and that new ceo vowed to
increase accountability make decisions
faster and to improve product execution
the company then set super super
ambitious goals for growth including
increasing annual revenue to 7.5 billion
dollars and getting to 315 million daily
users by the end of 2023
now while twitter is trying to get their
[ __ ] together and get more revenue get
more users and hopefully get rid of all
the crypto spam that is in every single
one of my reply sections
elon musk was still trying to figure out
do you think twitter actually adheres to
free speech and so then elon followed up
with another tweet where he said given
that twitter serves as the de facto
public town square failing to adhere to
free speech principles fundamentally
undermines democracy what should be done
well bang bang we woke up this morning
and elon musk has decided he told you
that there would be
very very important ramifications if you
didn't vote carefully and elon musk the
world's richest man has taken three
billion dollars of his own personal cash
and he has decided to build
the largest position in twitter by any
investor in the world yes elon musk the
billionaire meme lord is now the largest
shareholder of twitter he spent three
billion dollars or so and has acquired a
little over nine percent of twitter it
reminded me when i saw the news of when
he did snl and in that piece he
specifically said did you all think i
was going to be a chill normal dude of
course not elon we just want to know
what exactly you're going to do with
twitter he now owns over 73 million
shares of twitter to 9.2 passive stake
in the company that stake is worth about
2.8 2.9 billion dollars
twitter this morning has rallied 25
percent so yes elon has made hundreds of
millions of dollars this morning simply
by going ahead and buying shares in
twitter and we've got this tweet from
tar that said elon musk now owns more of
twitter than jack dorsey the percentage
of shares owed elon owns 9.2 jack owns
2.25
elon is now the single largest
shareholder in twitter and then gabor
had a great tweet as well he said elon
musk just bought a 9.2 passive stake in
twitter should be interesting giving his
comments on free speech and open
sourcing the twitter algo now again i
don't know exactly what elon musk is
going to do i don't know what his plans
are but i do know that elon musk he
loves memes he loves twitter he loves
free speech and he happens to know how
to build big companies and so ultimately
this is going to be fascinating he says
he's a passive investor now he's not
going to take an activist standpoint but
if all of a sudden elon decided that he
wanted to start firing away and actually
wanted to get involved in the business
could he join the board of directors
well he's the largest shareholder what
happens if elon musk became ceo of
twitter that would be wild but wilder
things have happened i don't know where
we go from here but i do know that elon
musk owning twitter just another thing
for us all to pay attention to hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time